join me perhaps you may be able to help
solve the mystery
[Music]
[Applause]
there's no time 13 o clock and it's
episode 96 counting down to that big ol
episode 100 we'll get there get there we
got we got some plant for oh yeah yeah
this one is Robert Stack attack right
yes talk about unsolved mysteries cuz
you know it kind of came up in a
discussion between me and Jenny about
how our show really is starting to cover
a lot of the different kinds of subjects
that were covered on the old show
unsolved mysteries and then we started
talking about Robert Stack and that'll
show and brought back a lot of memories
you know and we decided we wanted to do
a show on that show we're doing a show
one show on another show it should be a
fun show yeah yeah I came up was because
I was like like look I love unsolved
mysteries I used to watch it with my
grandma like at her house cuz remember
got ever like lifetime and all that back
in the 90s yeah used to show well maybe
a lifetime those ladies yeah maybe early
2000s but they used to show it like all
day like 11:00 to 3:00 it was a part of
the daytime television schedule so on
days I didn't have to work cuz I used to
work at night you guys so on the days I
used to work when I lived in Daytona or
my grandma lived she's passed away but
um I used to go over to her house and
hang out with her Brock and we would
watch unsolved mysteries and it's such a
big part of my formative years unsolved
mysteries yeah you know for those of us
who are from the pre-internet era yeah
this was our version of the paranormal
internet scene unsolved mysteries in a
way was almost proto Internet this show
was actually getting feedback solving
crimes and they were updating stuff they
play an episode everybody to watch it
and the masses would figure out and
solve that crime and then they would
call back that a whole call center and
everything yes
early crowdsourcing so early
crowdsourcing was almost kind of like
Frodo television based Internet yeah it
was quite cool I actually got the idea
to do this because I was telling you
about a really interesting article that
I read on cracked a couple weeks ago
that was like one of their slice-of-life
kind of articles yeah about somebody
that used to work in the unsolved
mysteries call-center hmm and I was so
fascinated by this article and I was
telling you about it yeah and you were
like oh man we should do a show about
unsolved mysteries just because when we
were first kind of conceiving the idea
of the 13 o'clock podcast yeah
that's kind of the same thing we wanted
to because they kind of cover it they
kind of cover similar times yeah they do
murders and kidnappings and abductions
they also do like weird alternate
history type stuff did you like lost
treasures all that UFOs paranormal and
it's one of kind of the early I mean I
know we had in search of and some others
like that but it was a lot better than
in search of it was kind of one of the
earliest shows that had paranormal stuff
on it like in wrong time and it was on
for so long it was in it was in
syndication for so long yeah and it's
weird because like you'd be in between
jobs you'd have to stay home that day
because you were looking for a job
through the newspaper or you worked at
night like never back when you tried to
find a job through the newspaper you'd
be like going to the newspapers playing
there playing that damn unsolved
mysteries theme I can't even do it along
with the daytime talk shows and that
sometimes you can catch it they've rerun
it way late at night like two o'clock in
the morning there's an unsolved
mysteries pretty cool the coolest things
on the best UFO episodes of balls of all
times came from this being did a lot of
good at yeah you know episodes yeah yeah
well the coolest thing about unsolved
mysteries and I mean from when Robert
Stack was on because it went to other
networks later on and there were other
hosts and stuff
we're mainly gonna talk about the Robert
Stack upsets cuz that's the ones I
remember most and and that's the
archetype and that's kind of the
archetypal unsolved mystery show like I
said they had later iterations of inator
hosts were good too it's hard to fill
his Robert Stack shoot right because a
lot of the mystique of the show a lot of
the mystery of the show came from his
narration and how creepy he was yeah
his creepy voice though there was only
one guy I thought that really could have
filled his shoes you knew it is oh you
told me yeah Keith David Keith David
Keith David would have made it awesome
he was in the thing he was in a life he
was in a lot of John Carpenter yeah they
live also yeah he also del the
voiceovers for like hey it was a LA
Confidential and we're yeah I think what
was it called was that program that
heaved all the voiceovers for yeah it
was for other crime drugs you need a
true my voice to do that and why is that
good a really good one and yeah Keith
Davis is an awesome one too thank you
David had that damn stage presence cuz
he looked like a badass yeah and he
could use classy you could be put a suit
on you know I mean he he was kind of
like - reminded me of James Earl Jones
it's gonna be kind of an unstructured
show we just want to talk about our
memories of the show a little history
the show this is gonna be kind of a fun
and entertaining show I got my mojito
right sorry it's a drunken show yeah
we're all ready we're already feel good
yeah it's all good I got a vodka
cranberry today cuz we're out of orange
juice is flaming red look at that isn't
it alright so one of the first shoutouts
we're gonna do okay so if you didn't see
our last movie review we did the arnold
schwarzenegger zombie drama yeah
which go watch that if you haven't
watched it already now you wanted to say
something about another Ernest movie
where he was playing against type that
was also very good yeah that's right and
now after he did Maggie and I watched
that I was like you know that that's
quite cool I like that did that now it
motivated me to get aftermath from 2017
and as we said our friend Matt also
recommended it yeah and he said this is
a disturbing flick man I think you'll
like it though if you like to Maggie
like this one so I watched aftermath
yeah aftermath is good too
if you guys like Maggie go see a
straight I know this is gonna be a weird
things because I really liked Maggie a
lot yeah I think I liked aftermath
slightly better it's a little disturbing
it's not what you expect has nothing to
do with his action career and he is
really playing against tightening yeah
really yeah
and yeah and he did a pretty good job I
I liked it yeah I did a pretty good job
I'm gonna say I think his acting was
slightly better in Maggie oh I think it
but I liked in aftermath that he was
just playing so out of character yeah
that I really really were there was a
couple times there were he wasn't that
one scene where he's driving around that
truck and he looks out the side window
he gave that Terminator side you know
the way the script paints this story I
wasn't really sure how it was gonna go
and the end last act the last couple
acts I kind of expected it but it still
shocked my head can't you know you know
I was kind it was a good our flick it
was our film yeah Arnie's doing art film
he's gonna come out of sideways he can't
come at us with you know the
muscle-bound action hero anymore you
know I missed armor so he's gonna come
out of cinder a different direction
he's gonna play with our emotions yeah
he's doing playing with your emotions
playing with your emotions playing with
your mind you don't know what's gonna
happen see I told you I was I was I was
teasing him about it because he always
he Tom always tease me about being into
like art yeah and stuff like that
because I cuz I really liked like
cerebral films and art and this actually
had a lot of Europe famous European art
film guys behind this this was not
really weld Aronofsky was one of the
producers exactly like - no I'm not
gonna
I like - no but you haven't seen requiem
for a dream or any of the other
I gotta get Noah on blu-ray I love that
look I like snow it's kind of like
across tree and Prometheus and madman it
was pretty weird
Oh which reminds me that somebody Oh
somebody has recommended to me a movie
called
bad batch the road that is kind of like
a Mad Max type of movie and I think Jim
Carrey is in it that pie like it's a
fairly recent okay
so we're gonna have what you're into
watching that but yeah someone on
YouTube but I've got the manned
aftermath you can get it on blu-ray my
version I bought the cheap version I
think it was only by six seven dollars
delivered off eBay and it came with a
really nice cardboard cover that went
around the CD box a nice metallic print
on it Mattacks
/ and it's cool I got it so I got that
sitting up there in my collection one of
these days I'm gonna take a video of my
deep my blu-ray Club we should put that
in the hundredth episode because that's
one of the things we were thinking about
doing is that show you where all this
stuff is and give ya little clips show
you the house I'll show so maybe show me
certain things in the house I also want
to put baby cookie in the cookie because
we have the cutest kid now and also our
spoon and she's turning 1 some people
probably know what this studio is like
our office yeah we're worldwide from our
office Wow yes we sound like all big and
Pippin it's got Japanese robots
everywhere
movies books DVDs okay we got some more
stuff we got to talk about yeah so okay
now what else were we gonna talk about
oh I also wanted to talk about if you
would like to support the show I know I
say this every time yeah we have a
patreon account which is patreon.com
slash 13 o'clock and we also have a blog
at thirty nine o'clock podcast WordPress
comm and there is a link in the sidebar
that will lead you to a PayPal account
if you'd like to give a one-time
donation now our latest patron is named
Jen and cheese from Dublin Ireland Oh
awesome
yeah I really actually make no they
don't live here making tourists coming
back to coming to Ireland your ancestors
are all dead yeah but yeah but I was
gonna say too so thank you to Jen who is
our latest patron now if you are a
twenty dollar patron on our patreon page
yeah you guys got just a couple days ago
I sent out a whole bunch of little
packages and I hope you guys like it I
sent like it was kind of a grab bag
everybody does something different that
coddle that kind of align with who they
are
yeah they were either some of my books
if it was books that you didn't have
already or you know if you had just
joined you probably got some of my books
because you hadn't had them if you did
have all of my books then I tried to
find some other kind of cool things to
send to
some kind of I don't know like magazine
stickers yeah and I catches that stuff I
gave my wrap sealed new inbox pocketing
seven to one lucky to wanna try yeah I'm
gonna give you a hit he's one of our
oldest patrons what about that man he's
been with us he's one of the guys to
spend with us the longest so you're
gonna get my season seven haunting and
that actually was mine yeah but I never
opened it yeah cuz I had two of them cuz
I bought you one for a present and then
you bought one yeah I was so mad I think
I probably owe and I also want to
mention too and I think I mentioned this
on the last show that our fan duncan has
started a subreddit for the 13 o'clock
podcast and each okay yes so each
episode has its own he has been putting
up new forms for each episode okay so go
check that out if you're on reddit also
we kind of wanted to mention just really
quickly that I'm still working on
faceless villain volume 2 will be out
this summer I promise yeah it's almost
ready even though it's taking longer
than I thought because I was saying
earlier this big but this book is big
yeah it's gonna like way longer than
this book is better anticipated this
book is better than the first it's gonna
be like 600 pages and it's better than
the first one unless I take some [ __ ]
out if you like the first one you're
gonna love this one yeah this one is a
lot more in-depth it's gonna be much
larger and the audio book will be
subsequently much longer right and after
that I'm gonna try and get the third
volume out before the end of the year
but in 2019 I'm really gonna try to get
a new microphone to record this new book
yes we have a plan on updating a bunch
of [ __ ] but talk about in 2019 our next
project and we were just talking about
this is going to be we want to do an
expanded edition of the mammoth mountain
poltergeist yeah we want a better
recording of it we want a better book
longer cuz more stuff has happened and
when Ginny and I put that book out jenny
was kind of new to the peril
I had only written fiction up to that
right partner what nonfiction was new to
her and really at the time that we did
that project release date was important
we were trying to get it out pretty
quickly as possible sure and we wanted
it to be kind of dry bare-bones and
scholarly you know Jamie's written
several non-fiction books since then
bigger books more ambitious books we can
go back and reboot that first book and
do a lot better job well and plus I had
written some additional material for it
that was just it was just like a bonus
for the audience just for the audit I
would like to add that book I would like
to add some other things that have
brought the house some other things that
have happened like some updates and yeah
there's things with updating think
updating some stuff with read and Lois
you've learned more about the parallels
between that case and other cases that
we talked about that you discovered in
unseen hand yeah so that last chapter in
parapsychology and theories about what
poltergeist is I think we can do a lot
better do and I think I'd like to expand
that so that's something that we're
gonna that we're looking at doing in
2090 expect a 400 page book yeah we've
also been talking about maybe going on a
couple of investigate investigations
ourselves yeah and you know yeah and
some local areas we don't know if that
will be part of this book or another
book though that's one thing that we're
considering right there's definitely a
lot of new material that's come to light
and just look at what we're selling in
terms of the art book catalog mammoth
mountain poltergeists that first edition
that old school edition we're always
gonna have that book that's gonna be the
classic version that's like the abridged
instant version the quick version of
that case so it's gonna be a good source
book for say like a parapsychologist
but we can make that book a lot better
we're gonna reboot that book there's a
lot of stuff that could have been added
to that now we're a lot better at what
we do now you know we've been we've been
in this we've had a very steep learning
curve I think in the past couple of
years people with the podcast with the
writing books and publishing books and
everything like that you know when we
first started out I don't exactly know
what I was doing I'd written fiction and
it didn't sell very well the medium has
changed so much 20 years ago there have
been a lot of middlemen in this okay and
a lot of publishers all that's gone now
if you want to if you want to succeed in
the industry today you have to be
totally home brewed you have to do
everything yourself and that's that's
you know you have to learn it there's a
learning curve yeah and we have a you
know a small but tight audience at the
podcast and then you know on the YouTube
show so we're doing it the way everybody
else was doing it you know yeah this is
gonna be a good this is you know we're
having fun doing this and that's what I
like and the more that we get people
like interacting with us like are all
are kind of regular commenters on
YouTube and stuff that's like so cool
like every time my video comes up and
the you know you've get into discussions
with all the yeah well Jenny and I came
from subculture backgrounds and that's
all this is this is just another
subculture it's just an it's just an
internet-based paranormal yeah unsolved
mystery serial killer style subculture
you know yeah so you know we're getting
to know you guys and you guys are
getting to know us and we're gonna give
you products that you guys will enjoy
yeah you guys are so kind of on a Segway
of that yes now remember I said that
next time that we did a paranormal
episode which this sort of is even
though we're kind of gonna talk about
sure crime to but I said I wanted to
just kind of give a summary of a couple
of paranormal experiences that a few of
our listeners had because you kind of
solicited something from ours that's
right listen that's right
so we actually got a couple of we've got
some good stories and I wanted to kind
of put those in the world new set yet so
this kind of good ties in with the whole
until mysteries the same damn it yeah
never saw so consider this our new
version of if we can may be so bold you
know apologies to Robert Stack you know
where he is now he passed away many
years ago yeah
so our first story comes from a listener
named Christopher no good now he
actually volunteered to work at the very
famous Mansfield State Reformatory also
known as the Ohio State Reformatory yeah
now it's very famous because it's famous
for being haunted Ghost Adventures have
been there yes hunters have been there
it's probably the most famous because it
was where the Shawshank Redemption was
filmed great movie one of the best
movies really good prison movie I really
love this story is very good to probably
the best Stephen King adaptation other
than the shining yeah but they're two
different oh if you guys like that and
check out escape plan Arnold
Schwarzenegger and he's always trying to
build a collection okay so Christopher
actually volunteered to do kind of
cleanup work at this reformatory he's
like not so much because I believed in
ghosts but because the Shawshank
Redemption was felt Larry's like I
wanted to check it out and really check
it out for free sure so he said that now
while he was working there as a
volunteer he said how most of this stuff
was just kind of like you know you tear
footsteps and he weren't really you know
there was no one there or objects
falling over you couldn't really explain
it but you know he didn't really think
that much about it
right but he said no this one wasn't
really impressed him as well right but
this one day he said now this was pretty
weird okay so he says that he got some
of his cleaning stuff and he goes up to
this one block with this other volunteer
now he said now I should mention that
the prison is always cold all the time
like not like paranormal cold but just
here this damp and you know there's no
central system right because it's made
of stone and brick and stuff so it's
just really cold in there yeah he's like
we both had hoodies on that's how cold
it was it was kind of a cold day outside
so he's like we're both walking past
this particular cell and we hear noises
in there now we say go first we thought
it was a rat yeah like and we kind of
like looked over there like ooh hoping
to see like this big huge rat in there
cuz that was pretty cool so they look in
there and they said there's no rat in
there but all of a sudden they feel this
huge blast of hot air
he's like it was just like a furnace had
been turned on like in front
your face huh and he says I broke out in
a sweat and then he's just like froze
like what was that
so he's like him and the other is him
and the other person a blast came from
the cell
so he's like it freaked him out so bad
him and the volunteers took off from him
okay well they talked about it later he
said well maybe that was like just the
real furnace and maybe it was some kind
of glitch or something yeah but he said
over the ensuing weeks he was kind of
like it just kept bothering me and
bother me so he's like so I went to kind
of the person that ran the place or the
kind of person that they were working
for and that woman said that in this
1960s yeah a dude had committed suicide
by burning himself alive with a plastic
bag of machine fuel and a lighter Wow
and he's like where did that happen
guess where where that's a good story
right yeah that's good yeah and that's
pretty more like you've experienced that
myself yeah yes so I like that story a
lot now that's going yeah I mean it's
not poltergeist just put that into the
realm of haunting yeah that's kind of
like the the type of haunting where it's
just stuff like replaying from the Brian
yeah not so much interactive yeah
haunting but what's the other word for
it where it's residual there's no proof
that the actual entity of the Dead is
there interacting with you it's just
like an echo from the past maybe
something I'm gonna do with you know
quantum physics or something sure
there's no way of knowing this I don't
doubt it I don't doubt that something
like that yeah that'd be pretty clear
yeah I'd like to see it now the second
story comes from one of our patrons who
has named weapons and stuff Oh web is
his stuff yes really yes my boy his name
is what his real name's Liam Liam okay
yeah I mean me and Liam need to go shoot
in one these days well you'll have to go
a long way because he lives in England
so he the President had the same kind of
Arsenal that you could have had this
year so he's saying that he actually
worked in the Argus store in England
it's a chain there and what they do I
don't think I ever went in one over
there I mostly just went an Asda and
spencer but our the argos store is kind
of like the way they have it set up is
that they're trying to keep you from
stealing stuff so trying to keep you
know they're trying to keep down floor
space so what they do is they have the
store and it's like this huge basement
where all the [ __ ] is and you go in
there and ask him and then they send it
up like in an elevator right you know
what I mean it's just regular [ __ ] like
furniture and teapots and [ __ ] like that
so he used to work for five years in the
basement of one of these stores and he's
like pretty much my whole job was down
there you would just somebody would
order something he would you would pull
the order and you would send it up in
the elevator why not
now he's like the basement was super
creepy it was super big it was you know
some of it was made of stone so it was
made of brick some of it was obviously
older than other parts is a very old
building and same one you know he said
they could stock about 30,000 items in
the downstairs area now he said one of
the most interesting things that
happened in there this reminded me very
much of the Miami poltergeist case that
happened in the 60s in that gift shop
warehouse do you remember that I wrote
about it in the NCAA and they thought
that it was some guy that was working
there like he was the poltergeist rigger
because [ __ ] kept falling off the
shelves and stuff yeah it happened in
Miami this is very much like that
because you said one of the most common
things he's like you hear footsteps in
there things are moved around ya or are
dropped in the aisle without anyone
being around them or anything like that
he's like in fact it caused like a lot
of annoying problems because he's like
you had to know where everything was
because when somebody sent an order down
you had to know where to find it really
quickly in this big huge warehouse and
he's like and [ __ ] would be moved around
he's like you know one of the things
that happened one time like right after
Christmas they had like you know
somebody had ordered some strings of
like Christmas lights and [ __ ] like that
and they couldn't find them and then
they found him like way the hell on the
other side of the warehouse of way way
way up on this top shelf where there's
no way anyone would have put them there
sounds like interactive haunting right
so the management kind of thought that
someone was like [ __ ] around at first
but then they were just like look it's
nobody it happened over many several
years now he says that one thing that
happened to him was that he was there
working and well he said there was like
sometimes she would hear you would smell
like weird odors and stuff
to like kind of a nauseated odor or kind
of like an incense or it's like when you
really sell anything like that but it
was just like be quick and it's pretty
common in the lights would go out bulbs
would burn out more often there than in
other parts of the building which they
thought was very strange space at least
once a week they would have to replace
bulbs down there which they didn't have
to in the main store I've seen that
before yeah okay and he said that he
actually saw a figure walking around
downstairs sometimes when there was
really not supposed to be anyone there
he said the weird thing about that is
that if the manager was coming down into
the basement he's like the only way down
was like this really really noisy like a
staircase and a really noisy big metal
fire door so we think there was no way
that somebody could like sneak down
there because it was like super loud so
sometimes you would see somebody in
there when there's no nobody in there
but you hadn't heard anybody come in you
didn't hear anybody leave right and he
said so one time he said I was working
down in there with his coworker and he
was down in one island in the next aisle
he started hearing really really heavy
footsteps now first he thought it was
the co-worker so we didn't really think
anything about it he didn't hear the
door shut he didn't hear anybody coming
up going but then later on when he
mentioned it's the manager they said now
your coworker left like hours and hours
ago so he's like basically this person
must have just like walked down the
aisle like right next to him and then
just like vanished or something because
he's like that nobody left he sounds
like a residual yes so that sounded
super weird did he actually see the
Apple he mentions that he would just see
a figure walking around downstairs and
that's all the detail you like it maybe
like a shadow we're looking what looked
like a person out of the corner of your
eye yeah yeah so he said he saw that
many times so they said they found out
later that where the store was you know
maybe used to be a churchyard which
might have explained some other thing
but you know he's not super sure about
that he said another thing that happened
was that people that work there would
have headaches all the time but he's
like that might have just been cuz the
lighting was shitty we don't really know
I never I've never heard of any kind of
hauntings producing headaches but
possible well that yeah that kind of
said that could be a lot of things right
could be anything but the rest of the
stuff he describes is actually kind of
common yeah phantom smells damp smell
being moved around on the shelves like I
said that sounds that reminded me
immediately of that Miami warehouse run
because that was I can't remember
exactly what year it was it was in the
unseen hand I wrote about it I think it
was 1967 is a some 1966 and he doesn't
describe ever interacting with anybody
or responding so there I would you have
to tree have dropped back to residual
haunting which is something left over
from another era you know like a tape
recording like a tape recording and an
echo from the past that's actually more
likely to believe something like that
that I am to believe in interactive
haunting yeah you know I mean well I've
seen interactive poltergeist interactive
haunting could be part you know it OBE
of II mean I had an OBE and nd there's a
possibility it hasn't seen it I've never
seen it myself yeah that's what I'm
saying I'm just saying I never seen that
I've seen poltergeist active minor
poltergeist activity I concede that
there might be a possibility that
something that happened in the past
might procedure might residually hang on
the back of my NDE and OBE when people
die they go they leave yeah they go to
whatever reunifying I felt like I was
pulled into a higher realm as what I
felt like I wanted to gravitate into a
higher realm where I belonged
you don't mean where yeah so I would
think that most people when they just
die they leave yeah now I believe that
there's a possibility there's some
people might stay behind but I don't
think it would be for very long that's
just what I'm thinking okay they
wouldn't be why would you want to
because the way you described your OBE
and your NDE yeah it seemed like I don't
know if I'm putting words in your mouth
but it seemed to me like a pretty
pleasant experience is yeah it is very
liberating you're like wow this is real
oh my god am i right yeah you know I
don't know why anyone want to stick
around
I think residual hauntings are not
really spirits of the Dead I think
you're the effects of the past in other
words like emotional print has been put
into the background that living people
can somehow access in the way that maybe
somehow animals have instincts you know
and like maybe you have some kind of
instinctive knowledge that something bad
happened in this area you know I mean
yeah like living not so much the dead
yeah it's not kind of a case where like
you see a dead person like a ghost of a
dead person and they can see you know
real-time things I don't think that I
think it's more likely a lot of cases
since the instincts of a living person
seeing a person that died in that area
that person isn't there but it's just
your survival instincts have somehow
accessed you know I mean a recorded
occurrence in the environment as a
warning for all we know many of these
animals have those experiences like your
cat might be seeing something I always
have been there in the past I always
suspect the baby things
whatever she sits on the bed and
suddenly puts her head up and look so it
was that was it and I always tease her
I'm like are you looking at go-go's up
there I think she's imagining she
doesn't tell I think she I think she's
imagined but I've gone I think she's
actually imagining things
probably fantasizing you know about
chasing something she's like maybe would
I be a lizard up there but I've gone
into places to where I had a bad feeling
I know that that happened not very often
right I think I told you I'm a mountain
bad feeling I had a bad feeling before I
got there but later on I also had bad
feelings about places but nothing
happened
was that maybe just some kind of an
animal instinct that all humans and all
hand animals have to wear this doesn't
feel right
and did it necessarily have to do with
the place or it might have had something
to do with a person that was in the
place that's what I'm saying maybe a
person got maybe there was sick there or
maybe a living person that was in there
at the time was giving you bad vibes no
cuz what I had in there by myself was it
empty place in there by myself this
isn't right because I freaked out by
living people wrong work it could be
that you know if a person had something
bad happen to them in an area it leaves
something behind like what mr. Halloran
says in the shining you know I mean like
burnt toast yeah it leaves something
behind
I think they get the idea alright so now
that we alright now that we've done that
let's kind of get into I know it's kind
of almost to the halfway point but [ __ ]
it whatever time we'll just let it go I
don't really care so let's talk a little
bit about unsolved mysteries like I said
we both grew up in the 80s I graduated
my school in 1990 so you know 80s and
90s that was kind of my formative period
I guess and unsolved mysteries
I guess if from people of our generation
it's like such a big part of our well it
was very spirited it was pre-internet
and for you youngsters that they grew up
with the Internet you don't you don't
know how lucky you are because in our
day you only had two things television
broadcast tape TV yeah and cable
television and there weren't that many
channels so you had a limited amount of
input and everything that they were
sending you was really really generic
nowadays like for instance you could go
on the internet and find out anything
you want to know about any any subject
or any culture like you could find
anything about you know goth subculture
goth music not in our day yeah you know
they couldn't find it I didn't know
there was anyone else right yeah I
thought I was the only person yeah we
used to actually send that was like he's
just sent around chain letters yeah
looking for other gospel I Kaloyan
weirdo but unsolved mysteries was kinda
like a refreshing breath of air because
it was a weird program and it was
mainstream but it had a spooky yeah
presence to it from our point of view
back then and unsolved mysteries solved
Robert Stack and unsolved mysteries
solved a lot of crimes yeah they
actually ended up now I think that the
website claims that at least of all the
wanted fugitives they featured on the
show that they caught about half of them
which is pretty good I mean you know
they had later ones like you know
America's Most Wanted with that's
focused on nothing but crime crime whew
the thing I liked about unsolved
mysteries was that it was it was all
mysteries I loved the true crime [ __ ] I
loved the [ __ ] I liked that stuff but I
liked that they kind of did other stuff
too
I wasn't too impressed with the ghost
paranormal stuff did not like it either
yeah portably but the UFO stuff was off
the chain they did let pon you know like
the you have a Belgian triangle and the
way that that was presented did the
Phoenix like the Phoenix lights and I'm
not talking about the flares I'm talking
about the fans lights to separate a lot
of they just say even did you know what
Mac Brazel you know the place you know
with with Roswell they did every major
UFO case and they really did yeah and
they had work or whatever that was yeah
and handled they handled each case with
respect it was very good even though as
I said reportedly Robert Stack I mean he
was on The Untouchables right yes so he
kind of liked the idea of being able to
use TV to solve crimes like I said early
crowdsourcing so I don't know whose
initial idea it was - jello let's do
paranormal let's do lost treasures let's
do other stuff but he was not super
jazzed about doing the paranormal stuff
for the UFOs or anything but he did it
because he's like okay well the ratings
were good and stuff so he was a pro and
he took everything super seriously but
he was mostly in it to solve crimes to
bring people's bring people closure to
bring people because they did a lost
loved segment to like you know and they
would bring people back together they'd
been adopted or had lost their family
members or whatever so he was kind of
way more into doing that but he just
kind of did the paranormal stuff just
cause right although the interesting
thing is that as the show was originally
conceived it actually started in 1987 as
a series of like one-off specials I
think it was just missing persons case
it's like do you know where this person
is and they would do a Hagley remember
this right yes so that's how it started
out in 87 and actually the first ones
were not hosted by Robert Stack they had
Rayman birds as a couple of oh man yeah
and Karl Malden yeah did a couple of
them but then Robert Stack did like the
last four and then they were so
successful that they said man we should
do a whole weekly show about this now it
started that it started doing a weekly
show in 1988 and at first it was on I
think was at NBC at first and it was on
day night and it was really high ratings
but then they moved it to Friday for
whatever reason because that's always a
dumb night to move your show to back in
the old days when you couldn't record
that well you could record things but
you know you didn't have DVR and [ __ ]
like that you had a recorder like an
actual tape these kids only yeah they
were so convenient we didn't really
realize it at the time yeah this is why
I'm not a nostalgic person like a
psychic about music I am NOT nostalgic
about the complications beingness is so
much easier variant is so inconvenient
yeah and you can buy something and have
it delivered to you absolutely
well that's I mean you can just buy
something you don't have to leave your
house that's [ __ ] awesome I wish that
they had each so they were younger so
much more so much more efficient because
seriously I hate talking on the phone I
hate talking to people in person I hate
it you have to go you don't have to go
to those [ __ ] malls right those balls
that didn't have anything that we would
ever buy and yeah you're like yeah we're
you know we're some cool clothes I mean
it's I don't know it's just so much
better nowadays and I'm like I said so
that's good because I did not want to be
one of those old people that was just
like Oh back in my days [ __ ] was so much
better it totally what's it and you
still have those can't really know our
parents generation like I said I love
eighties music I'm not saying that I
love movies that came out in the
seventies eighties I'm not saying
they're like new ones to 80s music yeah
I like news new stuff too but y'all tell
you know guys I'm just town young
eighties music was superior even though
they need a lot of shitty 80s there was
a lot of shitty good ETA's music was
just better than a lot of this new music
she was it yeah but oh but I'll argue
that cuz I don't know a lot of super
newer music unless it's like in the
industrial and gothic well you're not
being force-fed stuff like we were
reinforced fat [ __ ] that's one of them
we should tape
yeah remember that yeah you would wait
all day for [ __ ] to come on we gotta
take a break though yeah yeah we got a
commercial right so let's take a
commercial break right now and then we
come back we're gonna talk a little bit
more about unsolved mysteries we'll talk
about some other some cases that were on
there and [ __ ] like that
so listen to some commercials and we
will be back a second in just a couple
minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right so before I forget before we
get into this what I wanted to mention
that our merch is not really all of it
is up to snuff so we're gonna come up
with some better shirts we've been
talking about that doing some new shirt
design because you know yeah we just
didn't really have time to make some
really good stuff and it really it's not
selling for the most part you know not
selling as well as it should be and
Jenny and I were talking about the other
day we had some really cool ideas we
think that you guys would actually like
better thank we you know in terms of
where's that wreck demon child ooh you
know I think we have we were talking
member we were talking about that yeah I
think that we actually can do a lot
better on that so I just wanted to
mention that yeah ever the next couple
months I might be like all right you're
probably hear a start you know plug in
merch and I'll probably make a
commercial for some some cooler merch
that I think will sell it'd be more
gothy yeah all right so let's get back
into talking about unsolved mysteries
know like I said the canonic unsolved
mysteries had Robert Stack as a host he
was actually on from 1987 cuz he hosted
some of the early specials and he was on
from 2002 now he actually ended up
passing away in 2003 now the show got
moved around a lot of different networks
right it was on NBC it was on CBS it was
like you know and for a while like I
said the ratings started to slip when
they moved is Friday night which is
always a dumb thing to do you know for
broadcast television because everyone
goes out like Friday night Saturday
nights no I'm staying in Washington TV
well at least back then and for a while
they also had Virginia Madsen
the actress who was in Candyman that's
where I know her from but she co-hosted
for a while just because they were
trying to bring in a larger female
audience I guess yes I thought was kind
of weird okay but whatever I don't even
remember that yeah and I don't remember
those either
I mean most of the ones that I remember
look this show like over it's however
long run because 130 years it's been
rebooted like many times we're talking
about like almost 600 episodes yeah
which is the cool thing about when I
would go to my grandma's house and watch
it you could watch it all day for weeks
and months and in new years and never
see the same I went on you I went on
eBay to see if I could buy these things
you can't buy these things there's two
yeah like I said there's just so many
somebody have to buy like these
compilations like they had a really cool
looking UFO compilation yeah all right
that four discs on DVD they don't make
it anymore but it you can still get it
for DVDs for about I think was $20 I was
reading the reviews everybody complained
that was only a small fraction of the
cases that they expected well I mean
what are they good as they do man cuz
there are so many episode there's so
many episodes they sell like treasure
chests full of them
I think it has like 50 is it an actual
treasure chest yeah it comes to show
that is badass 25 wasn't it like a
thousand DVDs that was like 400 bucks
okay and it was only a small fraction of
the episodes and they kept updating them
like yeah they update you know cuz
they'd find out new things that was one
of the things you couldn't watch all
these if you were to put these if you
tried to binge binge watch the entire
ensemble you would be 85 years old well
one of the things and this is funny and
this is one of the kind of formative
experiences of my youth I'd be watching
this at my grandmother's house and you
would see it and they would talk about
some horrible crime or some missing
person or something and then they would
talk all about it and I'd be like that's
so mysterious man it's unsolved and then
they'd go update and I'd be like oh
because that's the thing about unsub and
I kind of worry about this too like what
I'm writing about when I'm writing about
unsolved crimes right book is that it
seems it's very open-ended it's like
there's a lot of stuff is unsolved and
you're people are just like they get to
it but they're like wow that's
fascinating but then hear nothing and
yeah and I kind of feel like that
happened with unsolved mysteries a lot
too as much as I love the show so I was
always kind of like please update update
update okay and then there wasn't one
I'd be like [ __ ] yeah but you know I
mean you need to move on to the next
yeah you have to go on to the next one
ghost [ __ ] well I guess I'll never
figure that out but I should say that
the unsolved mysteries show like their
production company still maintains an
up-to-date website it's it just at WWN
salt calm and you can still send tips
they have huge summer
of like all the cases that run the
original show and then you can just
email them tips if you know something
about it go on youtube and watch old
episodes you are not you are tripping I
think I see guarding
I found we found like seven maybe seven
episodes from the first season one but
they've only been up for a month or two
so if you want to watch me they take him
down they take him down but you can
watch him on Amazon Prime yeah [ __ ] I
even went to dailymotion and I found
like two yeah that I found somebody had
reconstructed the season one Halloween
special the newer ones they're on there
ya know I think with Roberts - ya know I
was gonna say that the show actually was
bought by the the rights to the show was
bought by Spike TV in 2007 right around
there and they actually got Dennis
Farina the actor to do all of these he
did like a hundred something episodes
like her and 75 I've said something like
that but what they did on this was all
they did and I didn't realize this weird
watch because we watched a few of the
Dennis Farina episodes and they're you
know they're good but all they did was
repackage segments from the old show
this is like 2007 2008 2009 a lot of
these cases were like from the 60s and
[ __ ] like that okay and so if people are
still calling in tips like everyone's
dead by now yeah but they didn't like
they took out any references and how old
the cases were right like to try to make
it seem like it was newer okay because
remember when we were watching one of
the Dennis Farina episodes they riche
owed that [ __ ] segment about the
Queen Mary the Fonzie is the Queen
Mary's right and I'm like I have seen
this segment to the recycling box the
recycling the recycling the old material
and you think that people would notice
because everyone in this segment it
looks like something a tease right like
they all have the hair and the shoulder
pry the way that they're seeing as well
we own we own the footage let's go ahead
we might as well yeah it's not soft so
let's go ahead yeah I mean I think they
did update cases that have been solved
in the interim right but they pretty
much just repackaged stuff from the old
show that hadn't been solved and just
again what did they solve let's talk
about yeah let's talk about a couple of
cases that actually were solved and then
moon could talk about a couple of it
weren't solved now probably one of the
most famous ones that was solved and we
actually saw this segment on there the
other day
Jerry Strickland and Missy Monday now
this was the one
now remember Missy Monday she was 16
years old and she worked at like a gas
station or service station type of thing
yeah and her older her much older
boyfriend yeah that she had been going
out with evidently he kidnapped the guy
she worked with that she worked with
that was like the courier for the money
that had come there to collect the
receipts over the weekend and he
basically took her out and took him out
in the woods
yeah and shot him like execution-style
yeah I've seen sources say 10,000 or
11,000 that's still that's still not
enough to kill a dude but he did so in
1988 like pretty much minutes after
these to run unsolved but now they
didn't know at the time they knew that
Jerry Strickland was dating Missy Monday
who was a teenager at the time they
didn't know she'd been killed too they
didn't know she'd been kidnapped and
taken by force they didn't know they
knew that the guy was dead and they knew
that Missy Monday was gone so they kind
of said you know obviously Jerry
Strickland was gone too so they figured
that he had something to do with it some
people thought she was dead right also
been killed but pretty much you know a
few minutes after the show after this
case aired on unsolved Michigan we saw
it was like season 1 yeah 20 people
called in and said hey they live here
right in Moses Lake Washington yeah and
actually the funny thing is that the two
of them who had since married and had
children yeah we're watching the show or
like hey there we are yes they were not
surprised when the police showed up
they're like yeah it's us yeah hi so
yeah so actually Jerry Strickland did
end up he got life in prison now Missy
Monday she agreed to testify against him
and I don't think anything
happened to her because she was alive
she was only 16 at the time I don't
think she attempted to argue that he
forced her because obviously he had you
know I don't know if they were married
but they have had a couple kids by the
time they found him but she actually she
prosecuted
yeah she pretty much got off but he got
life in prison for doing that so that's
probably one of the most famous and I
think that was a season one case that
they solved there was also I remember
seeing this one do you remember this one
that we saw Gale Delano and she was a
single mother she lived in Maine in 1986
she evidently answered a personal ad and
then she disappeared remember we saw
this oh yeah yeah she was dating doing
personal personal so all this time like
they shot maybe somebody had killed her
like and killed her or her mom was
thinking well maybe she threw in some
bushes and her mom was like maybe she
got amnesia like maybe something bad
happened her she doesn't remember she's
from well guess what she went off on her
own and committed suicide
yeah they found her motel right found
her eventually in boville Alabama so
yeah they did find out what happened to
her later she flew off to another city
checked into a hotel and killed herself
with a drug overdose
yes her family didn't know who she was
because she had stripped herself of all
ID yeah I'm waiting to identify on her
and that's why she did it
they found her right after she killed
herself but she was missing in the other
and where her hometown for what how long
remember how long a year to two year two
or three years yeah I said oh yeah we
found her a long time ago she was dead
in hotel room yeah so it's funny
sometimes you hear these stories about
these people disappearing you got no way
no way did that person disappear because
she had a family she had all kinds of
stuff she had no reason to really
disappear yeah no she disappeared
herself do you wonder about that because
there's got to be a lot of that going on
yeah but to me it seems like I mean that
seems like an extreme I mean you either
have to be going through some extreme
[ __ ] or you have to have some kind of
mental problem well it seems
difficult she did why would you do that
abandon your whole entire life yeah yeah
her family and her kids and everything
she did have a mental problem her saying
that she had mental problems real it's
just that the rest of the population is
like oh come on can't be that bad no it
was that bad her mentally well yeah
sometimes it is and I'm not arguing that
I'm just like I know that it sometimes
it is that yeah yeah they have weird
chemical imbalances that caused them to
go into depressions and they start
thinking crazy thoughts and yeah kill
herself well the thing too is that ends
at all and this next case - I think that
they featured this on the show this was
the case of a guy named Sammy wheeler
and he had gone fishing in 1992 they
found his body in his car he'd been shot
six times and his wallet was gone so
they thought maybe it was robbery but
then like on the show they kind of went
into oh maybe it was his twin brother
maybe it was his girlfriend maybe this
other stuff but then they found you know
because they're always trying to find a
reason right even though random crimes
do happen you know I hate to say but
they do happen it's it's rare it's
usually somebody that knows you or has
something to do with you but sometimes
that's random and in this case they
found out it was it was just some kind
of random guy who just shot him and took
his wallet and he just wiped all the
fingerprints out of scar and took off so
it was nothing to do with him he just
happened to be in the wrong place we
talked about all this spooky stuff and
there's a storm brewing outside there is
I just heard a thunder all the trees are
but that's cool we can pretend that
Robert Stack is still with us and we can
like hear his voice like coming through
can you how much you can help you solve
a mystery you know you guys know we live
in Central Florida summer rains and
heart it storms every single day yeah
and it gets dark they had a drop of the
Hat every afternoon
all of a sudden it goes dark and just
yeah yeah power starts flashing rain
starts falling is every single day well
you know it's tropical people always
think oh it's all sunny down here stuff
not in the summer
mojito is for as a poky it was for I
know man my [ __ ] cranberries almost
empty so another one that was on the
show how can you handle it how can I
have one handle the show because I
poured that so stiff it's not even funny
you got quiet you got because I must've
sad ass to resign obviously admit it
don't get triple it was that was a
triple yeah okay all right so all right
so here's another one I want to do
mention a little bit too now this always
featured on the show this girl's name
was Brooke Baker and she was a
journalism major in at a college in
Indiana now in 1997 so this was on a
little bit of a later shows although
like I said Robert Stack was on till
2002 they found her stabbed to death in
her bed in her apartment now a weird
detail that kind of came out about the
crime was that the faucet of her
bathroom sink was left on like it was
left running Wow
which they thought was very weird um
they thought maybe because she was a
journalism student and she had written a
piece for the school paper
about date rape yeah where she targeted
one of the local fraternities as you
know that's kind of where a lot of date
rapes are happening which I'm sure it's
probably true you know they thought
maybe she'd been targeted because of
that also they thought maybe there was a
police officer who was working on campus
I don't know if he was just like a
college police officers an actual police
officer that worked on the campus or
whatever but he was her landlord like he
friended the building that she lived in
now she had apparently moved to this
building you know because it was
supposedly safe but then she found out
that this campus police officer was like
sneaking into her apartment her
apartment at night and like going
through her [ __ ] and everything which
you know creepy so they thought maybe
maybe he did it maybe it was someone
that responded to an ad for a roommate
that she was looking for but later on
many years later they took DNA from the
cold-case files and they found out that
she had been murdered by another student
named Brian Jones not that one
no you know not the famous Brian Jones
he had also murdered another woman on
the same campus and had done the same
thing leaving the bathroom faucet on
it's not weird I wonder why that was
like his
he evidently used to be the roommate of
Brookes boyfriend huh and he just
decided he was gonna stab her and leave
the bathroom sink on but they did catch
him and he had caught another he had
killed another woman also on this other
case - there were this was actually from
1987 now this one displayed pretty
creepy
Kerry Lynn Nixon and she's 16 she was
going to the grocery store for her dad
likes to pick up him stuff she went to
the grocery store she came back she was
seen less than a thousand feet from her
house and yet she disappeared huh right
and they nabbed her right and they never
thought I didn't know if she just ran
away or somebody abducted her or
whatever now they said one of the
creepiest things that happen in the
interim while they were investigating
this case was that her parents had
actually seen footage of a New Kids on
the Block concert of the 80s and they
could have sworn that they saw her in
the crowd right and so two members of
New Kids on the Block like when in the
media and we're like hey if you ran away
Kerry Lynn Nixon please come home your
parents are looking for you and stuff
like that yeah but then the person who
it actually was it wasn't her right came
forward and said no that was me that
wasn't your daughter well turns out in
1994 they found her body very not that
far from her house in a shallow grave
[ __ ] turned out that a guy named Robert
Anthony Jones said that he saw her at
the grocery store followed her kidnapped
her raped and killed her and buried her
knew in the woods he didn't know where
he just started a store yeah
and decided yeah that that was a lot of
that [ __ ] is that yeah and I know that's
that's like really scary there was just
like a random thing like they you know I
know unsolved mysteries they have to
have like you know maybe it was this guy
baby this guy maybe it was this guy that
knew her but sometimes it's just some
random [ __ ] that saw you in a
grocery store and decided they were
gonna kill you so that's a little scary
I never want to go outside again yeah
also this one was actually quite famous
not necessarily because of the
disappearance but because of something
that happened afterward but this was a
kid named Michael Henley he was nine
years old in 1988 he went camping with
his family
in the zuni mountains now only a few
minutes after they got there
he disappeared they searched the area
they couldn't find him anywhere now you
know the family look the police looked
they couldn't find him
a year later and I think I might have
mentioned this if we ever talked about
Tara calico that very famous
disappearance yeah because in Florida
there had been this convenience store
and there was a van parked there and
then somebody saw like a Polaroid that
was left in the parking spot of this
convenience store remember that that
showed like a tied-up teenage girl and a
little boy with a book with a book and
with a thing over their mouth
okay well that photo ostensibly of Tara
calico they're not entirely sure michael
Henley's family thought that the boy in
the photograph
Neuros him so they made like a huge
media blitz about it and stuff but then
it turned out in 1990
yeah year after the photograph was found
they actually found Michael Henley's
remains okay and it turned out that he
had not been murdered but had wandered
off from the campsite and had been
killed by a bear probably huh and he had
been missing for two years they said
yeah he was definitely killed back then
like when he wandered off and it was
definitely an animal probably a bear so
it was just kind of an accident
they never did identify those two so
that so that boy in that photograph is
still not identified okay and actually
even though it was that girl actually
Tara calicos family believes that it's
her yeah but I mean there's no way of
proving it because they've never found
her they do most of the family members
do think that it's her it does look like
her I must admit but it's hard to tell
right you know what I mean now this was
another one this guy this one kind of
creeped me out too and this is another
thing where it looks like someone that
knew them did it but it wasn't this was
actually turned up on a 1995 episode and
this is the case of Dorothy Donovan so
this happened in 1991 and there's this
guy Charles Holden he's at a fast food
place and he told police that he's like
this guy I didn't know came up to my
truck and said he needed her bride
because his sister was having a baby and
he had to go to the hospital
so Charles says at first I was kind of
like now I'm not going that far
only live a few blocks away but then
finally the guy was kind of insistent
he's like okay fine well I'll take you a
little way and then I'll drop you off
and then you can get another ride so he
says he drives his truck and this guy
like about three miles down the road and
then he stops and he's like okay man
this is as far as I can go I got to turn
around I got to go home he tries to let
the guy out and the guy gets really
upset and starts like attacking him like
asking for his money and he said I'm
taking your truck and all this other
[ __ ]
so Charles jumps out of the truck and
runs to a store that's nearby like ask
him for help but evidently the guy that
he that he gave the ride to had a
screwdriver and like started chasing him
yeah so at this point Charles is like
okay well where do you want to go I'll
just take you just like just you know
don't hurt me so the stranger goes
around to the other side of the truck to
try to get back in and then Charles just
takes off right now here's the creepy
thing so he drove around for a little
while trying to lose the guy so then
Charles drives back to his house now it
happened that he lived with now he
called the cops yeah
so they met him back at his house now he
lived with his mom who was like 70 years
old Dorothy Donovan or he or his mom
lived on the property she lived in her
farmhouse behind his house now when they
went in there to check on her she had
been stabbed to death what damn now at
first because Charles had told this
crazy story about this guy that had
burnt up so that her want to ride a bla
bla bla they thought that he did it
right so for a long time they thought it
was him but then the cops like
interviewed people at the restaurants
that they said no I saw a guy came up to
the truck and was that and was asked for
a ride it was actually kind of weird and
stuff and then in Dorothy Donovan's
house they actually found a palm print
in blood like on the banister in the
house and the DNA wasn't his so
obviously someone else had been in there
so they had a description of this
stranger and stuff like that now they
did solve this case in 2006 they
actually were able to match the DNA
evidence to a guy named Gilbert e cannon
it was from Delmar Maryland and he had
previously been in prison for another
murder from 1997 now he just said all he
all his excuse
was was that he was on drugs at the time
and he was just looking for a place to
stay and he said he just picked
Dorothy's house at random because there
were no lights on and he thought no one
was home weird and then when he went in
there so this was another case where the
police were like oh it's totally the Sun
right is he had this wacky story about
this guy that came with a screwdriver
and [ __ ] it was totally unrelated but it
was totally well it was the same guy Oh
was the same guy yeah but he had
actually evidently he had gotten out of
the truck after he chased the guy he
circled back because like I said Charles
had driven around for a while he was
trying to lose the guy she goes back to
that goes back to that guy's house yeah
like nah I guess not knowing which I
said I picked that house because the
lights weren't on okay but that was that
dude's mom weird so like I said that
[ __ ] does happen that's crazy right now
so we've talked about a couple that were
solved let's talk about a couple of
things that is coming down it really is
here that jeez holy [ __ ] Florida Florida
for all we know hurricanes coming
straight is not a hurricane but a
tornado well it might be although I
would I would get a warning on my phone
if that was the case my phone just
vanishes if there was a tornado warning
it was bleep my phone so let's kind of
talk about a couple of the kind of
famous cases that were on here that have
not been solved such as the case of DB
Cooper oh yeah they actually recycled
this segment a whole bunch of times
they're never gonna solve this because
this has never been solved I'm going to
think that they could solve this you
would think that but now here's the
thing though I kind of feel like I mean
everybody probably knows the story of DB
Cooper he was a plane hijacker he stole
a bunch of my jacket planes jumped out
the back up and jumped out the back of
it with a parent with a parachute yeah
well he had four parachutes right that
they gave him he was planning ahead he
demanded those parachutes yeah so like I
said he wanted heaven back so he stole a
bunch of money and jumped out of a plane
after hijacking the plane he didn't hurt
anybody yeah he might Jack the plane
because he said he had a bomb yeah but
he ended up jumping out of the plane now
they don't actually ever know what
happened to him did he die when he
landed
did he land safely
and then change his name and cheese down
some of the mud he found some of the
money because when he asked for the
ransom they did actually take down every
single serial number of all the bills
that were giving him because he asked
for a particular amount he wanted two
hundred thousand dollars in small bills
I don't know how they wrote down all the
serial numbers in that amount of time
they know in a machine I think machines
in 1971 yeah it would have been probably
like a punch card type of [ __ ] but you
know same type of thing but so later on
they did find a few I don't remember I
think it was only what $3,000 $5,000 I
want to say something like that where
they were stashed in that band yeah they
were kind of stashed in the sand around
the area where he might have landed
right but they never found his body they
never found the rest of the money and as
far as I know the rest of the money with
those serial numbers has never been
right used although I'm not sure how
stringent they would be on checking back
not stringent you could spend that I
think they were all twenties if I'm
remembering correctly I mean if you just
went in [ __ ] winn-dixie or whatever
it just bought second check of frozen
orange juice with a $20 bill right
no one's gonna check that unless they
had a reason to yeah I mean the only
reason they checked the ones that they
found was because they were found where
they thought he might have planted he
made a big deal about the fact that well
those bills never seem to have recert
re-entered into circulation
now [ __ ] back in those days you
could put those bills back in
circulation they would never know like I
said they wouldn't know they wouldn't
check numbers unless they needed to
unless there was some other suspicion
yeah oh it wouldn't check it
automatically it was 1970 it was 1971
1972 oh I was guest on a show I think I
might make this paradigm a difference
parable yeah yeah and they asked me
about that recently and I was like oh he
got away with it you know but like
here's the thing I'll tell you this much
that was not his first jump
that was an ex-military guy who had
jumped before yeah I had the confidence
he needed at least the basic knowledge
that you'd have to well he particularly
to know said when he was buying the
ticket back in the days when you could
just walk into an airport by ticket
never twice first 20 bucks
those were the days where they didn't
have to like check in a year [ __ ] or
anything they specifically said when he
was buying the ticket he asked what type
of aircraft it was so he knew so he
because there was only one particular
type of aircraft where you could
actually like open the door and jump out
there's like a section of the tail
control press it has a loading ramp on
it yeah put stairs so he wanted that so
he could jump so he could jump out and
so he was looking for a 727 and he knew
about what altitude you could jump from
and he knew the speed yeah water but
slow down at 200 200 no big deal because
what he did like I said he didn't hurt
anyone he was on a particular flight he
told one of the flight attendants he had
a briefcase and he's like look I have a
bomb he's like I want you to land this
in Seattle or wherever it was and then
bring me $200,000 I want a flight to
wherever you have to fly at 10,000 feet
or whatever it was so he didn't hurt
anyone he just beeped the plane landed
everyone got off and pretty much
actually the passengers that were on the
original flight where he showed the
person the bomb none of them knew that
the plane had been hijacked until after
they got off and they were going through
the airport and then the FBI person had
said hey what did that guy look like he
knew that because he was a hijacker he
knew the flight they didn't know he knew
the flight path he was speed so he knew
about where he would be at the time of
his job so he had it planned out he knew
where he was coming out I mean he
clearly had this kind of never I never
found the parachute they never found a
body they found some of the money I
think that I would find something that
was white that was kind of floating in
the water they never like apparently
didn't ever got it I think that he made
it most likely he made it and took the
parachute with him he must have had
somebody on the ground waiting for him
that's what I'm think well that would be
the smart move
riah to have somebody waiting for you
and then pick you up and drive you up in
a car yeah cuz then you can just put all
your [ __ ] in the car and they get up I
mean I don't know why they found that
particular butt but it wasn't it was
only a fraction of the amount that he
had stolen it seems like he maybe he was
trying to reduce some of the weight that
was on him or maybe uh it was a
diversionary tactic look we'll hide a
couple of grand here in the same
and they'll think that I drowned
something like oh yeah like that [ __ ]
man that yeah he was like yeah I'll just
leave a couple thousand here so there is
a chance that he did die there is a
chance he landed in the water and
drowned and the body was never found but
you know it was it was wasn't that
desolate of area from where I'm not
really it didn't seem like and like you
said he seemed to have a good idea of
where of where he had to jump out what
particular did jump out what altitude he
had to jump out at like where he was
gonna land that and just to attempt that
means that you had experienced a job
which tells me he's price is gonna pay a
trooper that's yeah somebody from the
82nd yeah I'm be even think of that or
to even like one attempt that you would
have to have some a lot of knowledge
about yeah I wouldn't risk it without
though there's no crook that would
attempt a jump like that without any
experience just a first-time show no
you'd be saying and maybe he wasn't
saying but I doubt it I doubt that that
was an insane guy yeah it didn't seem
like so we're kind of leaning toward
maybe he got away more Ranger
paratrooper or something like that
guy yeah I go back and forth times I go
back and forth on it in those days what
he asked for was a lot of money be like
true that was 1971 yeah and I was it
equivalent of like a over a million
dollars so I mean 200 thousand dollars
now does it sound like a lot exactly
that would have been about like a
million now another case that unsolved
mysteries did kind of a two-part episode
on I think this segment was recycled a
bunch of times on many subsequent like
what is syndication stuff was the
infamous Son of Sam
killings oh yeah now ever since 1979
when convicted Son of Sam killer David
Berkowitz yeah sent a book about
witchcraft to the police were he and
then he kind of started insinuating that
he was in a satanic cult and that he'd
had all these other cult members that
had helped him commit the murders so
since that time there's been a lot of
speculation over whether Berkowitz acted
alone or whether there were other gunmen
now I should say the unsolved mysteries
segments on this and like I said it was
on two separate episodes like in two
separate segments and some of the
evidence was kind
compelling I mean they did make the
point that now some witnesses did see
people that didn't look like David
Berkowitz some people saw cars
other than that driven by David
Berkowitz I know what it's like all the
some of the descriptions of the killer
of the shooter were very different than
what he ended up looking like yeah I you
know it's like I don't know like yeah it
could have been more than one person but
see here's the thing I saw I saw it yeah
whenever I saw the witnesses I heard
their story it was just it was just
here's the thing whatever you're a
serial killer well one serial killers
are obviously not the most stable
individuals yeah cuz look at look at
Berkowitz he's just a big baby
he's just an in cell really it's all he
was the thing is shaken girls
particularly boys yeah it's like
particularly after they get caught I
think they kind of want the notoriety
they kind of want to be seen as like
these big bad evil yeah people so I you
know they will kind of confabulate oh
I'm in a satanic cult and there are all
these other people so trying to be
morning
he was just trying more than what he was
right he's trying to be bigger than he
was other than just some schlub that
goes around shoot that's what he was he
was a schlub that shot women with a 44
bulldog special so and you have to think
too that particularly late 70s early 80s
there was that a whole satanic panic
thing we did a whole show about it there
was so much of that in the media where
everyone was like seeing satanic cults
around every corner so he might have
known that he could tap into that
paranoia
yeah about Satan you know I'm not saying
that there aren't satanic cults in real
life I'm sure there are a couple of
losers somewhere that have some kind of
you know one of these satanic cults or
it's like oh we're gonna sacrifice kids
yeah let's bunch of wannabes that's I
mean it's usually a bunch of like stupid
teenagers and I don't you think they
would bother doing that anymore but like
maybe back in the 80s that was back in
the day right whenever I go I'm so did
oh man yeah yeah so like you could
pretend you were about us or whatever so
I can see that back before the Internet
yeah so I'm not sure I'm buying like I
can see why unsolved mysteries wanted to
do a two-part segment on it because I
mean Son of Sam is like a huge case and
a lot of people are still fascinated
with it so I can see why they wanted to
tie in that whole maybe it was a satanic
cult kind of angle but I
think I was really buying it like it is
weird that I mean they showed a lot of
the witness descriptions and they said
look how different they look and I'm
like yeah they did but they didn't look
different enough that it would have made
me think that it was different dudes
yeah I just think the difference is were
just because people were seeing it
differently because it was stress - well
stress it's like your brain is not gonna
be like super conducive to like getting
a good description of someone was doing
that was shocking one witness thought he
was an athletic really fast muscular guy
but that's you know that's because he
just saw that guy shoot some people yes
so maybe that was just his perception of
what he really was a little dumpy slob
yeah big ol spare tire around his waist
and there was nothing ethic about that
yeah just that well you know you when
you're under the effects of stress and
adrenaline you'll see the enemy as being
more fearsome than they really are
well I'm like I said you know when
you're just walking down the street
walking your dog or whatever you don't
expect to see some dudes shooting some
people in a car and you might only see
it for a second or like out of the
corner of your eye and I'm gonna tell
you right now I would be like the worst
witness ever because I don't usually
look at people I'm not staring at them
like trying to get every detail of what
they [ __ ] look like so if I was
walking down the street and saw like a
crime occurring I would probably not be
able to give you a very good description
of what that person looked like unless
they had [ __ ] horns or something like
that it goes back to that thing when I
was in the Army and I was watching over
that airfield in that yeah exactly
one-thirty came in for a landing and it
was orange and black and it was white
but it happened so fast and it was so
unexpected I didn't know what kind of
aircraft it was I reported it as like a
high-performance camouflaged jet and
then they go back it was a jet yeah it
was like yeah I'm totally sure so you
know it's an in Egypt at the time so
that was a violation was a little
treating that we had so we actually had
a deal and so we drove down there to
actually confirm what it was and it not
was an orange black and white c-130
cargo like a cargo fluid it shocked me
and scared me so bad I thought it was a
damn it some kind of weird attack jet
and that's what I mean and I think
that's the problem - and why and I mean
it's terrible and I know people say no I
remember and stuff but particularly
witnesses to a crime if you see a crime
occur that is something you don't see
every day
it is something that's very upsetting
it's something that's traumatic it's
like you are not in your best frame of
mind to take in all the details about
that yeah and like you said even
something that's not even a crime
necessarily like seeing a plane that you
didn't expect right you thought it
looked totally different than what it is
remember it I got on the intercom and I
said I said plane just landed it was a
military plane we got to check it out it
went it went out of my field of vision
after a raid it's hard to explain for
something that wasn't there but the jet
came in for Lynn and I watched it for a
good four or five seconds and then it
went out of my field of view and I got
on the intercom and I said we just had a
violation a military jet just landed and
they said what what kind of jet wasn't
it says I don't I don't know well how is
it paid in and I'm going it's some kind
of camouflage military pattern it's
still kind of a tag jet you don't know
and they're like you don't know the
model jet it was what kind of jet and it
was an American Soviet Air what this is
I don't know we got to go over and look
at it means start Smith piled into a
little vehicle that they issued us we
drove down to the other end of the
flight line to go see where they put
that that vehicle and it was a white
orange a black c-130 cargo plane yeah
and then look at me Ross we talked about
it was jet I thought was Janica swore it
was camouflage and they were like Ross
are you it happens when they ask you for
description you know it said well it's
writing a letter at the time and it
surprised me you just saw it real quick
real quick next is it was some kind of a
military aircraft you know I think it
had a camouflage pattern I think it was
a jet but I don't know we got they knew
it because they had been in the same
situation military observers all the
time know these effects that yeah you
can't really run some surprises you
can't really remember exactly what it
you saw which is one of the things that
kind of gnaws at me about some of these
UFO reports yeah definitely you know I
mean cuz that was in a way my version of
a UFO you know and I know that military
pilots see things that that they don't
expect to see are these and cops also
are these extraterrestrial craft are
they experimental terrestrial craft from
you know Special Operations military
units are they you know extraterrestrial
probes man I I've been in those shoes
before but when you have three different
police departments and like I had to up
to a half a dozen police saying yeah we
saw a silently moving triangle and what
was that yeah that's a reason that the
only time that I will actually listen to
witness testimony is if there are more
than two people that independently
report they say anything without knowing
about one another right and there are
some really good reports between
aircrafts seeing the same object at the
same time talking to the tower or
talking to the control tower hey we see
something moving it's it's you just the
size of it you know
yes see that's harder to discount launch
of different people saw it on that
particular night and they reported it
separately and they were they pretty
much described a similar thing or the
same thing and that's how I will always
remember unsolved mysteries because
unsolved mysteries had a lot of those
cases in it they really kind of only had
the best ones yeah their UFO cases
really kind of that's what got me
because I mean they're pretty much every
single show had three or four segments
on it so they spent like 15 minutes kind
of going into and they really did seem
to make an effort to I mean they got the
cops involved they got the family
members involved if it was a crime or
whatever and they really did seem to do
the reenactment as accurately as
possible yeah they did they tried not to
embellish too much it seemed like not
like a haunting like we're always
bitching about they really did seem to
try to make it look like and actually in
the earlier specials they didn't even
use actors they use the actual bridge
people they're one of the best with that
they did one of the best shows on the
pond Belgian wave yes that was pretty
interesting also
they had some stuff on the Phoenix
lights yeah they did do an episode a few
days and that was that kind of an
earlier might have been season 1 season
2 there was really something to the
Phoenix lights not the video there's a
famous video of the fest that's
notthat's flares later yeah after the
actual sighting I want to know why all
those people were calling 911 a huge
wave of 911 callers a lot of people saw
that thing and it was there was multiple
viewings it wasn't one craft it was
several and over stood over two
different states so there was something
to it I want to know more about it yeah
like I said we're not saying it's UFO
but that does seem weird that so many
people called in saying you know the
same thing and a lot of people kind of
described the same thing a big v-shaped
craft with lights on the bottom of it
and they could see through the v-shaped
craft wood that's odd really specific
details
yeah and they could see through it
slightly and the stars would kind of
waiver like kind of like a mirage which
tells me some kind of cloaking device
and maybe in those days they had small
enough cameras and LEDs to project an
image of what's behind an object to the
front like an LCD screen there was a
tease that would have been decades ahead
of the technology yeah it's possible you
could have had a an Air Force
surveillance craft that was covered in
an LED screen to project the nighttime
sky on its front but how would that
truly be stealth
who cares if somebody sees it optically
you're really only worried about radar
signature you know so would they have
built something that big like a big
Zeppelin big v-shaped Zeppelin with an
LCD screen on the front of it I don't
know I don't think they would have done
that in the eighties cuz radar radar
ruled the skies back in those days true
and yeah you can make it really who
cares if you actually see it you
actually want people to see it so they
see it they reported as an
extraterrestrial craft and it's not
believed yeah then they have possible
deniability they could just like the
aliens
yeah aliens yeah or you guys are just
crazy weird never there were a couple
other cases that I kind of wanted to go
into a little bit but the way
I didn't want to go into them because I
might want to do whole shows about him
at some point but remember they did a
show about because they did like lost
treasure type stuff and a lot of stress
they did and one of the best ones that
that was the Beale ciphers which are
very famous but the funny thing about
the show that they did about the Beale
ciphers and I don't know if you know but
this was from a series of letters from
the 1800s that were coded that
supposedly said that there was some big
treasures like gold and silver and
jewels and stuff and that it had been
buried it was like 43 million dollars I
think it's the value of it nowadays so
they have all these people out there
looking for it now one of the it's three
different ciphers one of them has been
interpreted but the other two are not
yet as far as I know but the funny thing
about the unsolved mystery segment that
they did about it was that they had
these two groups of people that had
spent like all this money like looking
for this treasure and they were looking
in totally different places even though
they both claims that they had solved
the cipher that said where the treasure
was but they were in two different
places and I don't know man it's like I
always kind of feel like all these
buried treasure stories I'm not saying
it couldn't happen that somebody buried
some treasures will write them but I
think 99.9% of them are just somebody
[ __ ] around when it comes to the
unsolved mysteries series it was awesome
especially in the day they were you
actually catching crooks too which I
really liked that but most of the crime
stories have aged out now lot of yeah
that were in there were solved what
really holds the fascination for me or
the UFO cases that they covered and like
you said the lost treasure case yes I
really like to get like a compilation of
all those yeah yeah I'd like to get a
couple of them yeah neat they're out of
print but you can still get used ones
yeah and you can buy some of the old
ones that are still evidently new in the
box which I might do it but but boy
they're expensive but like I said I do
kind of wonder like why on the
true-crime ones why they didn't do why
they don't produce I mean I know why
because it's too expensive but why they
don't produce newer segments like for
the ones with their own spike TV because
some of the cases are still being solved
cuz like I said their website is still
live you can still send them
tips like there was a case of a girl I
can't report her name was but she was
actually found raped and murdered like
behind a school nearby she went jogging
behind there all the time and they've
just found her raped and murdered back
there and her case was not solved for
many years they finally in 2016 they
finally solved it through DNA they found
the guy that did it he was just some
other student or somebody that had seen
her so they did finally solve it so I
feel like they have the website and I
like that they still have it that you
can still send them tips but it's just
kind of a shame that they don't produce
newer I mean I feel like they have been
talking about maybe updating it for
Netflix which i think would be a really
good because I mean look how popular
true crime [ __ ] is on Netflix I mean
[ __ ] we've been watching that series the
staircase yeah about that one Merton was
it a murder was it actually is the
future that's what they need to focus on
yeah so I feel like if that's where to
buy this and look what they do with MST
exactly and that's really awesome so I
feel like but if they're gonna do it I
feel like they should put the money in
and I'm not saying oh we should abandon
the old cases because a lot of those
cases haven't been solved and they
should probably just bring him but they
could bring them back if they haven't
been solved they could update them with
new interviews they could do like they
could film new reenactments or whatever
so to get people to kind of you know cuz
I know it sucks and I've write about a
lot of cases that are you know 50 60
years old and most of the suspects are
dead and [ __ ] like that but it's like
you still kind of want to know what
happened still so it would be good if
they could do that yeah but I mean there
was a couple other case I want to talk
about but like I said boy are we running
so long but we've been running so long
like I said I might do a whole show on
the Beale ciphers I also wanted to do a
whole show on the circ of the circle
ville writer because they featured that
on unsolved mysteries at least one will
do shows on but yeah that's a whole
that's a whole complicated topic unto
itself so I guess we'll just do a whole
episode on yeah we'll shut it down this
is good enough for tonight yeah so but
we've gone on for such a long time so I
guess we will wrap this up even though
like I said I think we only talked about
unsolved mysteries for like the last
half of the show but whatever
so remember if you liked the show
remember to Like share subscribe and all
your social media and share with all
your friends tell everybody about us so
we can just get bigger and bigger and if
you would like to financially support
the show remember to go to our patreon
page which is patreon.com slash 13
o'clock or go to our blog which is 13
o'clock podcast WordPress com and
there's a link in the sidebar to a
PayPal account where you can make a
one-time donation if you'd like also
check out our Zazzle store at zazzle.com
slash 13 o'clock i'm gonna be adding
some new shirt designs probably in the
next couple of months so keep an eye out
for those also check out our latest
movie review which was the arnold
schwarzenegger zombie drama Maggie if
you haven't seen it yet and remember to
check out our regular episodes every
Tuesday and our movie reviews every
Friday and that will do it for episode
96 see you later bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you